I'll ask the question fellas when was
the last time somebody got you a dozen
roses and a box of chocolates for
Valentine's Day fellas okay when was the
last time somebody took you out to
dinner maybe paid for the hotel on the
bottle of champagne when was the last
time fellas that's all I'm saying nobody
said that Valentine's Day was only for
the men to treat the women where does it
say that is their manual my girl
my girl
talking about my girl that is very
disingenuous of you
it's like a wedding is not geared
towards the women if both people are
getting married my girl
my girl nobody said that men have to
propose to women
my girl [__] my girl that is very
disingenuous of you
just look around you look around what
the marketing is geared towards okay
look at the colors look at what is used
my girl stop
stop hey baby you know what you need to
do
I want you to get in your little group
message and ask them how many of your
girlfriends have actually taken the boys
out for dinner on Valentine's Day
we'll wait
and we're gonna wait a long time that's
just disingenuous of you and you know
and deep down inside you know it is some
things aren't said they're just implied
they're implied by Behavior they're
implied by action that's gone over time
and time again nobody had to write a
rule book on how this goes but if my
wife did not get me a dozen roses which
she never does on Valentine's Day I'm
not gonna hold it over her head for a
year let me walk in the door and say I
don't need them that's the whole point
she doesn't need them either she got
everything else why you need flowers you
got Louie bags Gucci shoes you got me
why you need all that stuff it's a
holiday for both of you guys to
celebrate your love for no [__] that
[__] it's a marketing scheme all right I
don't celebrate it at all I celebrate
the 23rd of May what's on the 23rd of
May absolutely [__] nothing
people thinking that Valentine's Day is
romantic it's not it's a day that is
being expected
it's not romantic it's the opposite of
what it is if I surprise you on the 3rd
of April for no goddamn reason pedals
rolls on the floor when you walk in
bubble bath and champagne you know
you're going about you're about to get
your ass ravishly eaten
yeah that's romantic as [__] my [__]
that that that day is not romantic
pick a Roman at a random date that
that's that [__] right there
that's that [__] when I go when I go to
the grocery store and I buy some flowers
for my girl and the cash is like oh what
did you do
did you [__] up no [__]
I know how to treat my lady you got a
man no you single that's why we don't
bring flowers because we [__] up
sometimes it's not Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day is the least the least
but if you if that's for me
but if you want to celebrate it you know
damn well is geared towards women
if your girl forgets it that's fine
nobody bats an eye
if you forget it [__] if your girlfriend
gets it
when did they ever remember to do
anything for us
when did they even have that thought are
they doing that's their birthday not
let's let's no Valentine's Day yeah yeah
on Valentine's Day because you said when
so I thought you went in Valentine's Day
absolutely not but but no but hold on
but hold on hold on hold on hold on I'm
not gonna be as decision as this girl is
there's some girls that there's some
girls out there I know you I know you
girls you're out there you're Champions
you want to plan something for y'all
I know you plan it and that's not what
we talking about that's not what we and
you we know you're there I don't we know
you're there I don't believe it but it's
a few of y'all not a majority let's be
honest yo sorry to disturb you I don't
really like astrology like that but
facts are facts and if you are in
Scorpio you're most likely a Valentine's
Day baby yep your mom and your dad had a
little bit of friction on the 14 do you
know what the hell happened after that
and you could do the same thing too I'm
not talking about having the whole ass
baby no I'm talking about giving the
gift that keeps on giving orgasm
sometimes it's hard to reach the places
that you need to reach right you need
the proper tools for that like just like
whenever you fix your engine in order
for you to go to a zero to a hundred
from no room to room room you understand
what I'm saying yeah before that my boys
I suggest you uh the low-key wavy two
Motors 12 settings soft skin in order to
reach whatever you need to reach we on
King Shame around here and my girls just
for you this Valentine's Day we got the
Sona 2 Cruise Sonic clitoral massager
instead of having a good old vibration
it plays with the air around
the round if you understand what I'm
saying
[Applause]
click on the link below they have all
sorts of discounts on the Lilo help
yourself Valentine's Day is coming and
you could too
all right we celebrate it every day
I'm a celebrating wait you I mean you're
so busy maybe you don't have time to go
to you know a nice dinner that's your
argument you're gonna delay the fact
that I'm busy [__]
oh man how are you preparing for
Valentine's Day no you just dismissed
him you just dismissed the whole point
of what he was saying as a single man
how are you preparing we don't
if you think I'm doing something on
Valentine's Day with a girl that ain't
my girlfriend you a weirdo I would I
would do the same thing I would do I
wouldn't pull myself a glass of wine I
have a bubble bath and then after that
beat my meat like every other day that
day is not special what you gonna do on
Valentine's Day uh what day is it
Tuesday cool I'm gonna do my leg it's
legs this leg day that's that's it what
are you gonna do I'm gonna go to work
because it's a Tuesday do you do on
Valentine's Day Russell Dorsey he's not
so I'm not preparing what is there for
me to prepare
dinner for myself
I don't know do you go on a do you go on
dates or do you think going I think
going home and eat some chocolates going
on a date uh on Valentine's Day as a
single person is like the people that go
to the gym on January 1 you get in the
way of all the other people trying to do
things right like let the people who've
been in love like have their time at
restaurants let them have the the uh the
the the reservations move out of the way
right go on your date the next day I
don't even yeah I don't celebrate it but
uh you guys do you
you guys do you but my girl
my girl you got to be better at arguing
than this because that's not an argument
the minute you didn't have no argument
you switched to the other one all right
maybe you're too busy maybe you're too
busy and that's why I'm not even
listening it's not even listening no
okay okay
nah bee
my girl come on now hey man listen
everybody got their own definition of
romance if you if it's dinner in a robot
hey kudos to you I ain't even mad
remember one day I walked it he came
back from a trip walked into the room
and I dumped all my clothes on the bed
and then left and then took a shower and
I came on everything was all folded and
prepped and I was like yo Michael did
you do this she said yep I said
[__] I'm in love you're about to get
your ass
I best believe I'm appreciative and then
you go take out whatever I mean you know
to me it wasn't a specific day it wasn't
this Grand thing in fact I would say
this is probably more impactful to me
than a birthday surprise
to me's the little things but hey we all
a bit different would you want to say I
think we're the same on that [__] and
sometimes but people really think it's a
big things you know yes the big thing is
surprise but the little things
what you mean you you you bought me
socks I hate to buy socks yeah you
bought you bought the plastic fairy
keeps stealing my [__] yeah I don't know
how socks keep disappearing oh where's
somebody else's socks it's all Goblin yo
I know it's the little [__]
things people think it's really big [__]
and everything and stuff sometimes
sometimes you're gonna be like yo a
pizza
and falling asleep on some boring ass
Netflix that's that [__] right there
sometimes hey I just sometimes it's just
that I just want to say something
I don't know if y'all in a relationship
y'all out of relationship y'all want to
be at one but the only God says don't
take your partner for granted the little
things that they do make sure you
appreciate them you take a second to
appreciate them you tell us take a
second to tell them that you appreciate
what they do because it really is about
the little things
that's pretty much it men don't talk
[__] about you yeah yeah yeah Nano
that's pretty much it yeah that's that's
for another video